[Musique]
s'il y a bien une raison pour laquelle
j'aime habiter sur terre c'est que nous
ne sommes pas seuls
non parmi nous d'autres sociétés
secrètes et complexes cohabitent avec
l'humanité ils sont organisés ils sont
minuscules et ils sont fucking nombreux
même si certains décline un peu je vous
parle évidemment des insectes sociaux et
au premier rang desquels les fourmis et
les abeilles fourmis vous le savez
peut-être pèse plus lourd en kilogramme
que l'humanité bien sûr quand on parle
de fourmis on parle de milliers
d'espèces différentes mais quand même
leurs sociétés sont d'une diversité
absolument folle leur intelligence leur
efficacité corporelle et collective me
fascine personnellement complètement et
je suis pas seul comme dans ce
laboratoire du CNRS le CRCA le centre de
recherche sur la cognition animale allez
on y
[Musique]
va
c'est un monde qui est qui est tout
petit et qui a un peu ses règles propres
on parle souvent de la force des fourmis
leur puissance c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment lié à leur à leur échelle
exactement ouais c'est pas comme si les
fourmis étaient particulièrement forte
c'est que quand on vient à une toute
petite échelle la surface par rapport au
volume est très présente même une goutte
d'eau devient résistante donc leur
carapacees sont résistantes leur
puissance qui dépend de la surface
devient beaucoup plus développée que à
notre échelle donc elle nous paraissent
des superhéroïnes mais c'est du fait de
des des lois de la physique les fourmis
évoluent dans un monde dangereux
accidenté et sans papa ou maman pour
leur tenir la main forcément papa est
mort pendant la reproduction et maman
est constamment en train de leur faire
des petites sœurs d'un point de vue
cognitif la navigation est d'une
redoutable complexité les êtres humains
passent presque 2 ans à développer les
réseaux de neurones qui leur permettent
la coordination musculaire de la marche
et encore faut pas qu'il y ait de petit
lego ou de caillou sur le chemin d'un
bébé jusqu'à on va dire un enfant qui
est capable de s'orienter dans l'espace
ça va prendre des années ça va passer
par plein d'étapes les fourmis passent
aussi par des étapes mais ça va être sur
quelques jours donc on peut voir
justement ce développement une fourmi
naïve elle va pas s'éloigner du N elle
fait une petite danse qu'on appelle une
marche d'apprentissage qu'on a aussi
chez les abeilles un vol d'apprentissage
pendant cette danse elle va calibrer
plein de choses elle va apprendre à
découvrir le ciel comment il fonctionne
elle va apprendre les vues des objets
terrestres pour savoir la localisation
de son nid c'est que petit à petit
qu'elle va finir par s'éloigner en fait
avec leur cipat vous pourrez me dire que
c'est plus stable c'est vrai mais ça
fait quand même six pattes à gérer je
dire d'un d'un point de vue neuronal pas
mal toi les questions que tu te poses
c'est quoi c'est à quoi elle se fit pour
réussir à se repérer dans l'espace ouais
en fait ce qui est génial c'est que je
travaille surtout sur ce qu'on appelle
la plasticité cérébrale l'apprentissage
qui dépend de l'expérience et dans cette
tâche de navigation on va devoir
apprendre plein de choses mémoriser
plein de choses donc il y a beaucoup de
plasticité en jeu et c'est un
apprentissage surtout visuel mais qui
demande à être organisé d'un point de
vue spatial dans la nature les fourmis
font 1000 choses à la fois explorer
faire attention de pas se faire bouffer
trouver une trajectoire pour aller là où
elles veulent aller et être à l'écoute
du monde qui qui les entourent et elles
sont des milliers à le faire autour de
la colonie donc pas facile quand on a
une hypothèse sur un de leurs
comportement de pouvoir suivre les
fourmis une par une pour pouvoir avoir
une démonstration scientifique robuste
c'est pour ça que les observations de
terrain sont toujours couplé avec des
dispositifs expérimentaux en labo en
plus de ça les chercheurs choisissent
certaines espèces de fourmis en fonction
des questions qu'ils se posent là par
exemple comme Antoine se pose la
question de la place de la vision dans
la navigation il a choisi des fourmis du
désert pas une fourmie maniant
complètement aveugle et pourquoi tu
choisis d'étudier ces formmis là
particulièrement ah bah alors il y a
plein d'avantages méthodologiques déjà
on peut les étudier sur le terrain donc
par exemple quand on utilise comme moi
la vision comment elle se repère dans
l'espace on peut faire plein
d'expériences sur le terrain par exemple
on peut simplement prendre une fourmi
elle s'accommode très bien être prise la
déplacer dans le noir la relâcher à un
point B voir comment se comporte
enregistrer ses déplacements ça ça peut
répondre déjà à plein de questions aussi
simple que ça on peut faire d'autres
choses par exemple on a fait une
expérience on voulait voir comment ell
faisait pour gérer quand elles se font
déplacé par un coup de vent parce que ça
arrive dans le milieux désertique il y a
souvent les vents qui soufflent tu as
pris un ventilo et un souffleur de
feuill voilà et puis après des
déplacements ça nous a permis de montrer
des choses du point de vue cognitif
assez dingue parce qu'on a montré que
elle détecte la direction du vent avec
les antennes mais elles sont capables de
la lire dans le ciel avec un Compass
céleste donc il y a un transfert
vraiment de quelque chose d'égocentrique
à quelque chose de vraiment
halocentrique extérieur qui leur permett
de de mémoriser la direction du vent
alors ça c'est ce que tu fais sur le
terrain du coup c'est assez compliqué
d'imaginer ce que tu dois pouvoir faire
en labo parce que elles ont pas de
grands terrain à explorer elles sont pas
en plein milieu du désert donc qu'est-ce
que tu leur fais faire dans le
laboratoire bah c'est pour ça qu'on
utilise cette machine qui est une
réalité virtuelle pour fourmis dans
laquelle elles peuvent explorer sur des
distances infinies en fait c'est une
image projetée avec des LEDs ouais et la
fourmi est placée au centre là sur
tuattaches sur la petite boule là ouais
la petite boule qui flotte sur un
coussin d'air et du coup quand la
fourmie cherche à se déplacer en fait
c'est la boule qui se dérobe sous ses
pieds OK et nous on engiss le
déplacement de la boule et comme ça on
sait ce que la fourmie veut faire mais
on peut aussi manipuler l'environnement
d'une manière qu'on pourrait pas le
faire sur le terrain par exemple tourner
à gauche ça peut venir tourner à droite
c'estàd qu'elle tourne à gauche mais au
lieu que le paysage bouge normalement il
bouge dans l'autre sens voilà comment la
fourmie réagit est-ce qu'elle peut
s'adapter à ça ça nous indique beaucoup
de choses sur son cerveau ça nous permet
de tester des hypothèses qu'on peut pas
tester sur le terrain par exemple là
c'est c'est quoi les résultats que tuas
et les travaux sur lequels tu es en
train de travailler pour le futur là on
a réussi à faire des modèles vraiment
basés sur le cerveau des insectes qui
arrivent à faire émerger quand on les
met dans un corps et dans un
environnement un comportement qui
correspond à un vrai comportement qu'on
voit dans le milieu naturel dans
l'ordinateur dans le modèle informa
voilà sauf que on voit une énorme limite
à cette approche par exemple on a voulu
tester une prédiction de notre modèle si
on couvre l'œil de notre modèle et si on
couvre l'œil d'une vraie fourmi super on
voit qu'elles font exactement le même
défaut de locomotion donc ça valide un
peu notre modèle le problème c'est que
notre modèle il est coincé à vie alors
que la fourmi on a été surpris de voir
que 1 heure après on les voyait refaire
leur route sans problème notre modèle en
fait c'est une sorte de intenté un
cerveau et on a trouvé ces règles mais
en fait la fourmi c'est pas ces
règles-là c'est des règles de
construction qui ont amené le cerveau à
être comme ça tenter quand on l'a
regardé sauf que derrière s'il y a un
problème le cerveau va se reconstruire
autour elle va compenser elle va être
capable d'être résiliente ça fait un peu
écho à par exemple quelqu'un qui perd la
vue son cerveau va avoir une plasticité
pour mettre plus de place au toucher à
l'audition ces règles de plasticité on y
connaît vraiment rien donc on a une
chance de les comprendre avec ses
cerveaux un peu plus simples qui montre
quand même cette plasticité et ça c'est
vraiment spécifique à la vie une machine
exactement une machine comme nos modèle
une fois qu'elle est cassée elle reste
cassée quoi la question de la navigation
se pose aussi de manière passionnante
chez d'autres insectes sociaux les
abeilles qui appartiennent d'ailleurs à
la même grande et belle famille des
himénopteres comme chez les fourmis
elles doivent explorer leur
environnement pour trouver le succulent
nectare des fleurs qu'ell trforme de
manière complètement folle en miel en se
le vomissant de bouche en bouche passons
là-dessus ce qui est dingue avec les
abeilles c'est qu'elles sont capable de
communiquer la direction en dansant la
direction de ce qu'elles viennent de
trouver aux abeilles restés à la ruche
je le répète pour ceux qui ne le
savaient pas elles indiquent la
direction en dansant vous
imaginez
bah oui il y a pas moyen de laisser une
traîné de féromone dans l'air avec une
petite brise toutes les abeilles partir
à la dérive d'autres chercheurs du CRCA
cherch à comprendre comment un cerveau
aussi petit est capable de faire ce
genre de truc de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouf alors les abeilles domestiques
dansent quand elles reviennent à la
ruche avec l'information d'une source de
nourriture elles vont faire une routine
un
avec un zigzag au milieu qui va indiquer
aux autres autres abeilles la
localisation précise de la source de
nourriture qui a été découverte on sait
le traduire là cette espèce de langage
dansant on arrive à le lire alors voilà
cette danse elle a été observée depuis
des millénaires Aristote en parlait déjà
dans ses écrits mais c'est vraiment en
1945 à priori que Carl von Frich un des
fondateur de l'éthologie a compris le
code de la danse avec un chronomètre et
un compas donc en déplaçant une source
de nourriture autour d'une ruche il a pu
voir que les abeilles allaient changer
leur danse et que cette danse était
corrélé à l'emplacement exact de de
cette source de nourriture comment vous
vous vous vous posez encore la question
et quelle nouvelles hypothèses vous
faites et quel dispositifs expérimentaux
vous mettez en place alors ce qu'on
pense depuis une cinquantaine d'années
c'est qu'effectivement ces abeilles
indiquent un point précis dans
l'environnement une source de nourriture
un pot d'eau avec du sucre or depuis
quelques années on s'intéresse à la
façon dont les abeilles visitent
plusieurs sources de nourriture donc on
a commencé à faire des expériences où on
avait plusieurs pot d'eau sucrée et les
abeilles allaient visiter ces différents
pot et on s'est aperçu qu'elles allaient
quand même danser au retour à la colonie
donc potentiellement dans cette danse il
y a plus d'informations que ce qu'on
[Musique]
pensait et alors c'est quoi les
nouvelles expérimentations que vous
faites là c'est quoi ce truc alors ça
c'est un peu différent donc c'est une
façon de tester les capacités cognitives
des abeilles
en milieu naturel donc là aujourd'hui
bien sûr on est en laboratoire on est
dans une phase de développement mais ce
dispositif a pour ambition d'être posé
au milieu d'un champ et il va attirer
des abeilles domestiques ou sauvages qui
vont venir se faire tester pour leur
capacité cognitive pour obtenir une
goutte d'eau sucrée donc cet appareil il
sert à tester l'apprentissage visuel des
bourdons ou des abeilles et c'est pour
ça qu'on a des signaux lumineux à gauche
et à droite et ce qu'on va essayer de
faire c'est d'apprendre au bourdon à
associer une couleur à une récompense
donc on peut voir que lors des premiers
passages ils vont dans les branches
droites et gauche du labyrinthe sans but
précis ils cherchent pas vraiment de la
nourriture ils cherchent ils paniquent
un peu mais petit à petit au fur et à
mesure des passages par exemple au au
10e passage on voit que le bourdon a
appris et sait que à la fin de cette
épreuve il y a une récompense de la
nourriture et donc on voit qu'il panique
beaucoup moins quand il est dans la
porte et que en sortant de la porte
quand le test commence il va directement
à la récompense ou au moins il va à une
branche où il pense qu'il y a une
récompense assez vite aujourd'hui on l'a
automatisé miniaturisé et on l'a rendu
capable de d'être autonome dans un champ
et donc on va pouvoir comme ça tester
des centaines voire des milliers
d'abeilles sur des périodes très courtes
en continue et donc on va pouvoir
mesurer les la santé mentale de nos
abeille institue oui parce que leur
cerveau il est il est tout petit du coup
il est incroyablement optimiste elles
peuent pas se permettre de de perdre
quelques neurones c'est l'hypothèse
qu'on pose effectivement ces animaux
avec ce mini cerveau sont capables de
réaliser des des presses cognitive et
donc on pense que la moindre agression
du système nerveux ok la moindre
agression d'un neurone et bien va
réduire les capacités cognitive de ces
abeilles et si une abeille n'arrive plus
à reconnaître deux couleurs ou deux
odeurs elle n'arrive plus à choisir des
bonnes fleurs n'arrive plus à butiner et
donc si elle a une colonie à nourrir au
bout d'un certain moment la colonie
n'aura plus assez de nourriture pour
grandir ou si l'abille est solite et
bien toutes les larves qu'elle doit
nourrir vont dépérir donc l'enjeu il est
là aussi de pouvoir prouver que les
pesticides ont un impact
écologique sur les abeilles et du coup
sur toute la pollinisation alors bon ça
on le connaît maintenant les pesticides
ça fait une vingtaine d'années qu'on
qu'on a démontrer scientifiquement que
c'était mauvais ça on le sait il y a pas
de souci ce qu'on sait moins c'est
comment différents facteurs de stress
interagissent entre eux il y a des
pesticides mais il y a d'autres choses
qu'on a pas pris en compte jusqu'à
présent les métau lourds la malnutrition
les parasites et les pathogènes qu'on
importe avec les transports humains et
cetera et ces cocktails de de facteurs
de stress et leurs effets sur les les la
les pollinisateurs mais sont très mal
connus alors ici l'idée c'est d'avoir ce
capteur de cognition que l'on déploie
dans l'environnement dans différents
environnements avec des niveaux de
pollution contrastés pour essayer de
comprendre quels sont les cocktails qui
vont être les plus nocifs pour les
abeilles bientôt on va aller au Japon
par exemple à Fukushima pour étudier
l'effet de la catastrophe nucléaire sur
les pollinisateurs sauvages euh et puis
on a fait des expériences également dans
des mines d'or des anciennes mines d'or
qui sont extrêmement contaminé au métau
lourd et on peut à terme imaginer
influencer sur les politiques locales
hein pour arrêter certain certaines
pollutions ou au contraire favoriser
certaines actions l'avancée des
technologies nous permet de voir
toujours plus loin dans l'infiniment
grand et dans l'infiniment petit mais
ell nous permettent aussi de voir de
plus en plus précisément le monde
intérieur des autres êtres vivants qui
peuplent notre planète bleue la même
planète des milliards d'autres mondes
fait d'odeur de de couleur de rythme de
sensation qui nous sont inconnu les
progrès de l'éthologie nous montrent la
chance que nous avons de cohabiter sur
Terre avec des êtres si spectaculaire si
indispensable à l'équilibre global de
notre écosystème en découvrant
l'intelligence et le monde des insectes
c'est notre intelligence et notre monde
qui grandit est-ce que ça suffira à nous
rendre assez intelligent pour ne pas
finir tout
seul va
[Musique]
savoir